all right guys let's see if we're live
here let me know how everything
sounds how everything looks
here should be
live and I believe there we are there we
are guys this is hands down I'm going to
call it right here the absolute
strongest uh title Tuesday event that we
have ever had on chess.com
I'm looking at the pre-registered list
guys and I see Magnus Carlson there I
see Hikaru Nakamura there I mean uh I
see Fabiano Carana Grandmaster Wesley so
I mean this is unprecedented really this
is clearly the strongest title Tuesday
event we've ever had so I am so excited
to be bringing you guys the action here
uh on chess.com we'll uh definitely be
sticking with Magnus as much as we can
but honestly there's so many many uh top
players to to mention here uh we got
guys who are 2600 rated who don't even
make the top 20 um here at title Tuesday
uh dlugi nitzki mvl Wesley so Carana
Hikaru Magnus Carlson um going down the
list guys shimanov sjov um Dimitri
andreen I mean there's too many names
guys I cannot mention everything but we
will uh start by following the games
let's see round one here there it is and
that is Grandmaster Magnus Carlson
playing with the black pieces here this
is the first time Magnus Carlson has
ever played in a title
Tuesday um meanwhile guys uh let me know
chess.com TV I'm following along send me
your comments uh you know let me know
who you guys think is the the favorite
to win in this absolutely stacked uh
tournament and uh also let me know how
the the sound is make sure we're we're
sounding good here I'm also following
Along on twitch.tv/ chess so um
definitely stay interactive guys I will
be looking for uh your comments but
let's get uh honestly right into the
action here we got um Magnus Carlson
playing Black here against International
Master angry Serb so we got a we got an
an angry Serb here against Carlson in
the first round and guys this is a
pretty big deal because apart from the
blz battles this is a extremely rare um
public appearance for Magnus Carlson uh
you know playing online on a public
account that's a very big deal it's
always a big risk for a guy like him
because uh you know that's that's
actually him saying that you know it's
him playing on his account there's no
anonymity here so if he loses a game
that you know there's all the glory and
and pain from his side that comes with
it so A lot's on the line here for
Mangus Carlson uh first title Tuesday
ever he's clearly the highest rated
player um I guess we have to we have to
say he's the favorite I mean never count
a guy like Nakamura out who's won the
title Tuesday event many many times um
and there's definitely some Specialists
here but Magnus Carlson from what we've
seen in the blitz battles uh this guy is
is uh completely capable of competing in
the online chess scene which is really
the only question that we would have is
you know how would that obvious
dominance from standard and classical
chess translate to over the board bullet
chest stuff like that but he showed
especially against his match with hikaro
that he can hang with some of the uh the
very best um in terms of online play
rapid uh speed chess and even Blitz and
bullets so
um going back to the game here though we
have Magnus Carlson he's playing Black
uh it looks to me like I really like his
position here um I'm looking at the D3
Pawn I'm a little concerned about this
but my next move is is probably Bishop
to F7 and uh might consider a move like
King h8 Knight E7 C5 uh maybe even
Knight A5 if I need to kick the Queen
off that diagonal so I really like
Black's position here actually just
because this Pawn looks like a permanent
weakness and the only way that I know
how to get rid of this is to play the
move d4 but it looks like uh Magnus has
Consolidated here and there we go guys
how do we defend this Pawn so
essentially I'm expecting probably
Bishop F1 Bishop there and then Knight
E4 that looks like the only way and
black does want to be careful but
playing the move F5 if he plays F5 in
this position that E Pawn becomes a lot
weaker um and becomes a liability
something to deal with something to
defend so I don't think Magnus is
interested in doing that at all what I
would expect from him is trying to get
the move C5 in I think if he gets that
um positionally speaking uh I think he
would be very happy maybe something like
uh Knight E7 I don't think you want to
play this move while Knight G5 is
available although it looks like Rook f8
is hinting that the current world
champion wants to play F5 very fast play
from Magnus so far good to see that the
only way I can really see him going down
I mean simply the strongest player in
the world is is uh if the clock becomes
a factor and uh believe me guys the the
clock is a factor so absolutely
uh absolutely uh crazy crazy to see
Magnus here I hope you guys are uh
enjoying we got nine rounds of three
plus two action here so uh definitely
definitely stick around guys this is uh
going to be a fireworks uh episode for
sure we're probably going to see
Nakamura play Carlson we're probably
going to see clashes between Wesley so
and Magnus Carlson who people are are
saying you know online chess aside you
know Wesley and Carana these guys are
maybe the the two next uh guys who are
going to challenge Magnus Carlson so you
know when that debate comes into play
all of a sudden we have uh some really
important matchups for the uh the future
of Chess um so I am just so excited you
guys can probably tell I've never had
this much energy uh as a commentator so
I'm loving uh I'm loving the action so
far I hope you guys are as well again
Magnus is playing so fast here look at
the time does it even matter what moves
you're playing as white um is my
question H6 is stopping Knight G5 is is
what I was saying and after F5 F4 now
the move Knight G5 not available F5
kicks the Knight to uh D2 and oh opening
the position feels risky guys cuz you're
not even developed here these two pieces
are just not playing the game that's a
that H Pawn is a goner Magnus has barely
used a minute here is this material odd
show I think I usually do that show but
Magnus is doing some time odds uh stuff
to start us off here I mean that's just
a free pawn and okay this might be the
uh this might be the uh most crushing
game of the round although I see that
mvl has actually won his game already I
don't know if that was a forfeit win or
if he delivered maybe the fastest
Victory I've ever seen in a title tu
Tuesday I don't know about that all
right tricky tricky if you take either
Pawn we had Bishop E6 winning uh the
game but I don't think that tactic is
enough for for uh Magnus to fall
for got Danny rench in the
chat Fabby Wesley Hikaru and then in
comes Magnus yeah I I know this is uh
actually actually insane right now from
a chess fan perspective I don't think it
gets better than that uh reminder guys
there's just one Tittle Tuesday this
week so uh it it really just uh reminds
us you know just how important this one
is because there's no late edition uh
but on the contrary the prizes have been
increased so these guys are playing for
more money and uh there's also a lot
more pressure cuz there's uh there's
only going to be one qualifier this
month but don't forget in in April we
have uh four title Tuesdays in the month
because chest Doon members get a chance
to uh qualify for the speed Chess
Championship which has just been
announced and we might see just game
over with knight3 here and there it is
that's going to be a resignation Magnus
Carlson game over round one all right
let's go to the next game I'm going fix
the screen for you guys there okay we
got uh Nakamura in here against I
believe this is Alexander Catz crypto
chess I've seen seen his username and oh
I tune in and it's just over uh I was
going to say I've seen his username in
the proess league so um
International master from the US goes
down here in the first round and
honestly guys I I have so many games
that I could uh I could watch right now
I just recognize all of the
players that uh that I see here so who
do we have uh next next top game right
now still in round one lots of games
still going we've got Daniel nitzki he's
won the title Tuesday before as well and
it looks like here he's going to grind
down uh an end game what Knight takes E5
yeah no this this is uh this should be a
trivial win I think for for
Daniel wonder what you what do you do
here do you play Knight
F3 probably not huh Knight F3 then maybe
bishop
G2 and Bishop C8 I think is a huge
mistake allowing the the king to C7 and
now there's going to follow Knight D7
King D6 and that's lights out or just
King D6 right
now and there we go so Knight takes and
then Knight E4 and you kick the king out
Knight E4 Knight F6 and then King D6
black has no worries that's an easy
conversion as
well all right I'm going to leave that
game that looks like Daniel nitzki has
that one wrapped up um who else do we
have let's take a look at Grandmaster
dlugi over 2700 in Blitz that's a that's
a strong rating and it looks like here
Knight F2 forcing Rook takes F2 because
of the well-known smothered mate with
Knight F3 or Knight H3 Queen G1 I think
every chess player has to know that one
Queen E7 and sto being Queen E1 actually
we have to think here for a minute o we
can't take that pawn
though King
f8 ah how's he going to defend that pawn
though guys interesting oh this is a
repetition actually yeah that's a
repetition wow Lugi uh the more that I
look at this position though that's
that's not so easy let's take a step
back Queen E7 was there any was there
anything here maybe not
huh yeah wow that's uh that's surprising
maybe that was just uh a repetition on
the
board well that's uh maybe disappointing
result for uh duoi playing against
Grandmaster fishbine from the United
States as well but let's keep the uh the
action going here round one coming to a
close but uh this is actually the uh the
most that we've had most players that
we've had in a title Tuesday as well it
looks like oh this could be a huge upset
as well we have uh the chest bra here in
action oh that's a hanging Pawn there
that wasn't necessary two Bishops
against two knights I was going to say
there's a pawn extra for black that
could have been an upset but a big
blunder there by the national master and
O do you want to put the Knight on the
side of the board like that I'm a little
skeptical we'll see if the two Bishops
can hang with the two knights here is
Eric Hansen um against National Master
gomero is uh trying to uh give us a
bishop Clinic oh do you take that I
wonder because the the question is uh
you know can we run this way and like I
was saying guys you know the The
Bishop's just cutting cutting the Knight
off this this could be no this could be
this could be done the Knight can't move
guys you're basically playing down a
piece no this is as soon as the Knight
went H4 cautioning against uh cautioning
against against doing that and there you
go there you go that's what you that's
what you do you trap that Knight on the
side of the board guys um let's take a
look at this game fix the board as well
there we go Sebastian uh who I believe
is Grandmaster Len Dominguez uh Perez
from Cuba very strong player uh who
recently started playing on chess.com
which is always nice I think they call
him the uh the
scientist um for you know just his uh
he's got the glasses on he's got this
trademarked uh style that he likes to
play those very very small plus
positions uh that you know only a
computer and uh you know a cyborg human
would like and he he plays in the
Perfection so he gets that that moniker
from that basically he's got a draw an
end game here three against two we we
know our end games enough to know that
one Pawn is not enough to win however
this is Blitz guys um so we'll see if he
can manage to pull this one out I'm
going to stick with this one cuz this
might be the last game of the round but
uh just to update you guys on the
standings you know no surprises Wesley
so one his game Nakamura won his game
Carlson um basically everyone that we
expect kowana mvl so um doesn't look
like any big upsets in the first round
but seriously guys as I'm scrolling down
this list uh you know people are are
like 25th and 30th seated and still
rated over 2600 so uh this is uh really
crazy to see so many strong players out
uh in one in one event so title Tuesday
looks like it's going to be a good one
uh we're we're watching grandm Dominguez
see if he can pull this one out but it
doesn't look like he's making any
progress here the games are wrapping up
here in the first round still first
round out of nine again 3 plus two so
there's no winning on time in a position
like this that's why you 3 plus two is a
good timeing control you you get that
nice that nice kind of Chess where uh
you know no one's flagging each other
and you're you're trying to focus on
good chess good moves good chess and if
white wins this it's not going to be oh
do you play G5 here okay took with the
king I was going to say G G5 might be an
idea if you take with the pawn um but uh
right before black got away with a 50
move draw it looks like white plays G4
so I think we're going to be sticking
with this one for a while most of the
games have wrapped up yeah this is
almost the last last game in round one
here and I can tell you guys I am really
Happ to be commentating but oh man I
would have liked to play this one as
well so if you uh if you're a title
player and you're not playing this I'm
telling you you're missing out right now
you are missing out so F4 basically I'm
wondering what White's idea is if black
just stays here eventually we'll have to
bring bring the Rook down okay we're
going to see a check cuz black is
threatening uh to
play Rook to G1 and okay probably chck
and then Rook G1 or sorry chck and Rook
G3 but essentially uh I won't give too
much commentary here guys because uh
this is a drawn position and we don't
have to uh we don't have to look at it
too much we're we're just wondering if
uh if white is able to pull off the
miracle so probably H4 yeah just run
that pawn we're going to see white uh
try to confuse black but you always put
the King on f8 always King f8 I wouldn't
worry about losing your Pawn because we
all know the fidor technique putting the
Rook on A6 and you know sit back and and
earn your draw so I wonder if he's going
to do things that way that would be the
simplest I
think maybe push the pawn
here I I'm in the mood to just push the
pawn and get the Rook to A6 that's what
I think should be played um because hang
on in this position like how does he
even stop the pawn he might just have to
go for some kind of Perpetual there or
maybe check and then Rook D3 o I would
have gone check and Rook
D3 that seemed to to be good but okay
this one uh Rook D3 H2 Rook H3 there's
nothing happening here I mean it's
really really impossible to lose as
black now that you've got your your Pawn
One Square from
Queenie yeah now really T watching uh
watching is nice too you're right if
you're playing then you're not able to
watch all of the uh all of the games
that are going on and that would be that
would be a real shame so yeah I I think
these guys might agree to withdraw here
but if they don't unfortunately that's
that's more time that that we're wasting
here
but we'll wait for this one to get
agreed BJ in chat how you doing Kirkwood
chess there as well of course
vsim how you doing
guys okay let's have the handshake
time's getting low for black maybe he'll
give up his Pawn because he's uh
interested in making a draw that way but
I mean this this should be pretty
routine I think
oh okay never mind he he has this move
got a little scared about the the mate
but okay must have been the uh same
position a few times by now I you know
how it feels though being the higher
rated player in round one you're willing
to do anything to to take a draw or
sorry to avoid a draw and it looks like
that's what's happening here but no I I
don't think I don't think White's going
to manage this
one I think maybe around uh round three
then uh we'll we'll really start to get
the the critical matches between the the
top players in the tournament uh I don't
think we'll get those next round but
assuming that all the top players you
know maintain their their perfect
scorers I think we're definitely in for
a chaotic round three with some very
very big games finally agreed to a draw
it's a good thing I stuck with that one
I had a feeling that that was going to
be the the last game of the round and oh
hang on hang on is that not the last
game of the round what could go longer
than that oh
jeez wow and I show up here and actually
is
winning what happened so they were
playing this position for a while but I
show up and blacks just winning so w
that that looks like a big win there for
uh that's Grandmaster van forest from
the Netherlands recently played in The W
Ken Challengers group uh also a member
of the Montreal chess bras in the proess
league so uh there you go yappi too
showing that chess bra
technique and some pretty big matchups
in round two uh although not not the big
ones we're looking for let's check out
Magnus Carlson here with the white
pieces highest rated 296 7 that's just
crazy that is just crazy I will try to
keep you guys posted about any uh big
upsets in in the tournament but so far I
haven't uh I haven't seen anything too
bad okay is that D4 start but uh We've
turned this into some sort of modern
opening we're going to see Knight C3
usually it's a big Advantage when white
doesn't have to play the move C4
so if we compare that to a king's Indian
position where the pawn is on C4 this uh
should be considered just a big
Advantage we might see A4 here uh either
A4 or just Bishop back to uh D3 or E2
and he has gone A4 so if black plays A6
white will bring the bishop back and
probably play Knight to C4 I wouldn't be
surprised to C H3 here but another move
might be Bishop E2 um black wants to
give up the light Square Bishop playing
the dark squares but again without that
pawn on C4 it's a lot less targets for
the uh for the black Army
here so we might see what Knight C7
Knight D7 that seems reasonable Knight
C7 to kick the bishop back and then
Knight D7 to try to play Knight
E5 if I'm Magnus Carlson here though I
might bring my Bishop all the way back
to F1 we might see Queen D1 here there
it is Queen D1 this Knight will be
kicked out by the move C3 eventually but
uh until then it's uh it's really on
black to to show what's Happening Here
we might see Bishop F1 here uh and there
and there there we go Queen F1 and
Bishop F1 those moves might be
surprising to some of you um but I guess
the the reason I'm able to predict those
moves although they're they're both very
backwards developing moves is because uh
in this position white has a lot of time
it's a fixed structure Black's not in
any interest to open things up quickly
white wants to maybe put his Bishop over
here G3 H4 um but his main plan is that
he wants to play C3 kick this Knight out
um and I'm assuming his next move is
going to be some some sort of knight
move maybe Knight B5 A3 C4 some Dosey Do
With The Knight um or hang on how's he
going to deal with this Pawn now maybe
he doesn't care about it let's
see might see a queen move Queen B1 or
queen C1 and I do not think the idea is
Bishop H6 but we'll see I'm pretty sure
he wants to move the Knight and go for
C3 so basically that move is the same
idea as B5 that he wants to play Knight
E3 or Knight A3 and end up on that C4
square and basically we're we're going
to see a clinic guys um with two Bishops
that's what I think we're we're in
for E6 okay opening the position for the
Bishops you can't complain about that if
you're white C3 Knight A6 and I think in
that position you want to take on E6
although actually even if you let black
take you take with the Knight that's
still fantastic position so what is
black thinking about right here the
Knight only has one square unless I'm
missing
something yeah no I was wondering what's
what's going on so he does take and I
expect maybe G3 H4 Bishop H3 looks uh
looks reasonable Bishop G5 or Bishop F4
also looks very good uh E6 is a tough
move to play guys a Grandmaster simolo
from uh is that Egypt I believe Egypt
yeah I don't know who this Grandmaster
is I don't recognize the name but um
this looks like he's going to be in for
a a tough ride on the light squares
there for example how do we defend this
Pawn maybe move like Knight here or
Knight back okay Knight E5 um I was
going to say maybe Knight E3 almost not
wanting to trade but Magnus looks like
he's uh going to keep his two Bishops
and uh a move we might see in this
position is just Knight E5 if if allowed
so I would consider Knight F7 as black
keep the the pieces on the board I feel
like um taking on C4 simplifies in
White's favor this is definitely in
White's favor I'm so surprised he didn't
take that Knight guys Knight takes Pawn
takes is the worst structure I've seen
and you keep your two Bishops so I'm a
little surprised there but I guess he
sees he sees the Target on D6 and he
knows that uh there's no way that black
can defend it so we're going to see
probably Knight takes Knight here and
Bishop f8
no interesting Knight B8
well if Bishop here there's always
Bishop
F6 but it's definitely something to
consider Bishop G5 Bishop
F6 there's not Knight E5 but we could we
could take and take on D6 and play F4
and E5 yeah that looks reasonable and
Knight F7 guys thwarted by oops Knight
takes E8 attacking the queen as well
maybe that's what he missed I'm not sure
but he wants to stop Magnus from playing
F4 here black is going to play G5 I can
guarantee that so basically if black
doesn't play Rook f8 there he's in
trouble and yes the whole game is about
playing the move F4 so Magnus wastes no
time in playing it I wonder what his
idea is after Queen takes what is he up
to oh sorry that pawn is just hanging
there there you go that pawn is just
hanging and these Knights are are
looking a bit misplaced Knight takes C5
and yeah unfortunately this defends the
pawn on e4 attacks the pawn on E6 and
Magnus is just up two conect to pass
pawns this is uh this is just over it
feels like o careful now this Rook is
almost trapped to tra there as well if
you play Bishop E2 G3 uh looks to trap
The Rook okay Rook Rook D7 if the Knight
moves probably Bishop E2 A5 a lot of
moves to suggest here for Magnus but
I'll just let him display far better
technique than my arrows can um I think
he's got this game guys um I'm actually
going to leave it there because Magnus
more than 2 minutes on the clock he's
he's already shown us the clinic that
looks like a victory there's a lot of
other important games to get to uh gader
gusov um oh man this looks like maybe a
anti
Berlin yeah this looks like potentially
an anti Berlin opening and Huka really
going for the victory here in what
should be a dead drawn endgame dead
drawn but uh okay Knight
B5 Knight B5 is interesting there's the
possibility to always open the game with
H5 so NAA here with a 2 minute to 30
second Advantage uh playing Black here
against Grandmaster guso from aeran I'm
sure that he's going to be trying to
play for the win we know mag sorry not
Magnus we know Naka very well we know
Naka very well C5 is that the idea C5
and King C6 no B5 actually that's a
little surprising allowing A4 I don't
think that no I don't think Naka can win
this
that would be
impressive uh I'm guessing if if takes
the only way to keep it in balance is to
take with the pawn but I just don't see
the benefit in that um but with this
time Advantage NAA is really good at
creating issues or just things for his
opponent to to think about problems to
deal
with as white it's uh you know maybe a
little bit of a boring way to play but
hey draw against nakur in round two you
can't ask for a better result than that
and uh you got to play for the
tournament result not NE neily for the
fans okay so Knight C4 Knight C5 King
E7 I mean that realistically they should
uh just end up in a draw and a couple
moves but I think that's the exact
opposite of what we're going to see here
I'm I'm sure that uh NAA is going to be
playing this on for a victory and he's
turned some of these positions into
victories before so I'm not even going
toh question him I will let him uh
navigate that position as we move on to
um Demitri andreen who is a well-known
participant here in title Tuesday often
uh often finding his way to the top of
the table and he's got a three against
two endgame here with knights on the
board that should be another easy draw
but unlike the Nakamura position this
one there's actually um there's actually
some hope with the extra Pawn to to play
on
so white will definitely be pushing for
a win here realistically should be a
draw but uh you know there's 10 seconds
to a minute that's what we're seeing in
these games is the higher rated players
are essentially going to be um either up
material or in a drawn position or maybe
have a slightly better position or
trying to win but the the real
difference between ratings that I find
because I can speak for myself is the
time difference the the higher rated Guy
usually has a big time Advantage but
this tournament is 3 minutes plus 2
seconds so
there's no uh there's no flagging in
this event guys promotes some good uh
good chess so if anyone's going to win
it's got to be on the board uh the time
can play a factor but with 9 seconds
here you're getting two seconds every
move all you have to do is get rid of
every single white Pawn I think it can
be
done I think it can be done so is he
going to take I wonder I guess he've got
to take here Knight D6 King
D4 okay well there we go at least he's
uh he's got a Target here if white can
win that pawn he's really going to push
those two pawns for
victory he's going to push those two
pawns for victory Magnus and hikaro
still playing uh Wesley so as an update
two out of two Fabiano Carana two out of
two it's actually not Fabiano's first
appearance in the title Tuesday I
remember distinctly commentating one
before where uh where he did participate
but um it's maybe his second appearance
so Fabio Carana definitely not regular
he's off to two out of two that's a good
start uh International master or I
should say Grandmaster elect aat Chandra
also out to two out of two and ooh
there's no Knight to E4 there to trade
pieces but 3 seconds this Pawn on A4 you
start to worry about losing it what
happens after King B4 now Knight
E3 probably just Knight
C3 o hang on Knight C3 Knight C2 and
King C5
tricky what do you do here
Knight D2 yeah Knight D2 protect your
pawn and just take this guy next turn
what a what a series of events here just
take that and King
B3 wow guys he managed to win that pawn
and he's going to play King C3 Knight
check A4 and I'm going to call it I
think he's going to win the end game I
think he's going to win the end game
that is really really filthy what we
just saw not in a bad way I mean in an
impressive way uh Vlad mirovic Demetri
andreen pushing for the victory we're
going to see Knight D4 check probably
yep and
C5 okay he's threatening Knight C5 check
so you might see King back to C6 now C5
check I at or sorry not check just C5
and King B5 I think looks
good is he just going to go
back no he wants his Knight on D4 it
looks like that looks like the best
Square for it followed by C5 now it
switches to to uh this would be very
impressive if black actually manages to
hold this he's got an idea though Knight
takes
C4 don't
forget we might see Knight E6 here and
if Knight B7 what's the
idea ooh guys Knight
B7 Knight C6 is actually one of the
funniest zuk swangs I've seen this
Knight can't take either Pawn can't play
here can't play here and the King can't
move how nice is that
oh man that would have been
hilarious I guess maybe with his minimal
time on the clock he did see that which
would be impressive but um andreen
pushing for a win here let's stick with
this game and see if he can do
it and checking the standings for you
guys uh Magnus Carlson two out of two so
he also won his game but we checked a
lot earlier we had a feeling that that
game was going to be over Knight
A6 C6 check oh this is uh turning into a
real grind and there's threat of C7 and
Knight A7
check C7 and King D7 yeah that works cuz
there's no Knight
takes o actually there's no King d8
because of Knight E6
check so what is he going to do king
E7 that's a nice one if Knight there
then King back now he's going to play
King back this is a oh hang on a sec oh
I was going to say that was such a nice
game oh but now it's a
draw I think yeah King King B7
yeah and then just Knight C4 check and
Knight B6 or Knight
C6 oh hang
on man okay I'm pretty sure that it
should be a draw but uh yeah I think
he's got it now because he's going to
play Knight A6 next turn night A7 night
A7 oh
man oh
man what did I just see guys you have to
appreciate this end game this is one of
the nicest end games I've seen so I
thought that he messed it up so let
let's take a look cuz right here I
thought he was doing a very nice
triangulation and then Knight B7 King
there Knight takes King there this must
be uh must be a draw here must be a draw
I think you need to play King here so
that white goes here and you
play Knight there and then although
there's Knight D6 moves like that I
think you just put your knight to E7 and
control that square that is the nicest
end game that I've seen
though because you have to remember when
it started guys that was uh that was a
complete draw three against
two oh man so there was a lot of moments
in that end game which I was pretty
impressed with but the the Finish was
actually pretty nice as well Knight A7 o
and you win no matter what here because
your your Pawn Queen's on C8 by
force o there was a he missed a mate did
he miss a
mate no he didn't miss a mate 85 was
check what are you guys talking about I
don't think he missed a
mate no no you didn't miss a
mate all right
okay there we go what a nice game uh
let's take a
look at the
[Music]
standings where is Nakamura hang on a
sec did Nakamura
lose guys I think Nakamura might have
lost or okay drawn I guess whoa Nakamura
lost oh we saw the position where
Nakamura was basically playing
um we saw the position where Nakamura
was playing uh an equal
position
and oh man that's he must have tried too
hard to
win round three is starting guys we're
going to put Magnus
Carlson on the screen here let me fix
the board okay Magnus Carlson is playing
Black I'll flip the
board
oh man that might be some nacka tilt
guys oh let me fix this one sec got to
make sure
uh got to make sure we're plugged in
over
here there we go yeah guys nakamuro lost
that is inexplicable um it's happened to
me but that's something that's some
discipline you just have to take with
you at the highest level um you're
playing a low rated player you really
want to win that game but if it's a
objectively a draw you don't push too
hard it sounds like Nakamura obviously
pushed too hard
um and lost uh lost that end game that
is too bad for nakar one out of two to
start off but we've seen him come back
it depends if he stays in the tournament
or not but that is really too bad he
should have taken the draw and been in
totally fine contention with one and a
half out of two you could even call that
a Swiss Gambit guys he could have he
could have snuck in the back door of the
tournament so uh in this round we have
Magnus charlson here against Shrek David
um actually everyone's maintaining their
their big two out of two scores we've
got uh Fabiano Carana mvl Wesley so
Magnus
Carlson and depending how uh this game
goes we're we're going to check out uh
Wesley so's game uh as well because we
want to start following uh want to start
following some other games there's a lot
of people with perfect scores right now
and most importantly there simply a lot
of title players uh in this tournament a
lot of really really strong title
players so um I think maybe in the top
10 in the world there might be like five
or or six maybe four or five uh players
from the top 10 or something that's uh
that's pretty crazy Rook d8 rookie 8 I
think uh as white you know you're
playing the world champion you're not
too unhappy with an equal uh sort of
symmetrical type of position like this
but again in the last game when when
Magnus was black playing E5 always we
saw was him pressure the D Pawn we might
see him pressure that square again we
might see him pressure that square
again and what what is it why do people
keep doing this like ed5 is actually a
move that I uh struggle to understand
there okay
well once again we'll see if Magnus can
put enough pressure on the D Pawn here
takes Rook takes and is Queen C5 an idea
with Knight
D4 what does he want to do after Rook to
E1 that is the question looks like
Knight
D5 and then Knight D5 knight uh takes E5
there's Knight takes E3 very important
and is there no there's no F5
here no F5 there might be is there
Knight
F4 I think Knight F4 might be an option
option although Knight F4 you have to
think about D4 so tactics actually not
favoring Magnus Carlson there look at
the time situation a minute on the clock
Magus has 2 minutes and 42 seconds so
don't ever uh talk to this guy about not
being a speedy player look at
that well the move we want to play is F5
it's simply being prevented by this
Knight here Queen D6 runs into Knight F5
Knight
F6 I guess just Rook back how does
Magnus keep playing
here maybe a move like Rook E7
threatening
F5 that seems reasonable to me uh E5 is
not threatened Queen D2 doesn't seem to
threaten anything except the idea of D4
um I guess Magnus is maybe looking for
something that keeps pieces or keeps
material on the board because Rook E7
maybe D4 is what he's concerned about he
just doesn't want everything to get
traded off although it looks like after
D4 if you you take there everything gets
traded off but maybe that position is
still good remember white has his Pawn
on A4 and a lot of lines that's going to
be hanging at the end of variations so
we'll see what he does here Queen
D5 I don't know I would play uh maybe
this and Rook E7 trying to set up
something there King h8 bit of a bit of
a sneaky move there does he want to play
Knight G8 or
something King h8 maybe that's like a
you know pass the ball into your court
type of
thing you know he he maybe didn't know
exactly what to do but he's also
confident that white doesn't know
exactly what to do so he's happy to do
that now we might see Pawn takes here
because white is interested in keeping
the structure like that but he plays the
better move Rook takes which definitely
is
correct just I was going to say Rook E2
but Rook E3 just as good Queen
D5 basically these are the two
weaknesses in the position White's
goingon to put all this pressure against
E5 meanwhile uh at the end of a lot of
lines B3 or A4 the two weaknesses in
White's position are going to be hanging
so hang on a sec now what is happening
after Knight takes
Pawn oo maybe D4 is a good move but what
happens after Knight takes Pawn there
was I oh sorry no excuse me ignore me
ignore me what am I saying I was only
counting how many pieces were attacking
uh E5 but of course you don't count how
many pieces you count the value and
white would lose his Queen if he did
that so you can just uh ignore that
comment completely there you go if I was
playing Magnus I'd hang my queen queen
right there uh if Knight D2 Queen takes
is not possible because of
D5 so Knight D2 forces Queen D5 but
uh actually Knight D2 Queen D5 and F3 is
that
possible that that looks interesting oh
he he takes whoa oh tactics Knight C4
doesn't work oh Magnus with the
calculation hang on so if Rook B1 I
believe Queen A2 is quite
important yeah Rook Rook uh Rook B1
Queen A2
guys Rook B1 Queen A2 and this Pawn is
going to be hanging imagine Knight C4
happens there's just Queen takes and
Rook takes pawn and this is just lights
out I imagine Knight D4 looks extremely
strong
Knight D4 Queen D1 and there's no Knight
C2 because of Rook B3 I think or
actually he could play Knight C2 Rook B3
Queen
A2 but it you know it looks a little a
little weird in there basically Magnus
just won a pawn for nothing and he has a
extremely strong position so I don't
think he's too concerned after Pawn
takes the move F4 becomes uh pretty
strong we might see Queen C5 from Magnus
in this position that feels uh really
strong and if takes then we play
F4 Knight C2 he's going for it now ooh
guys he's going for it now look at that
he sees the move F3 exposes the diagonal
now Rook B3 there's Queen D4 check
basically the same tactic that we just
discussed and Magnus of course realizes
the difference in the
position okay there's no E5 trick which
I was going to say white might sacrifice
material but you've got two Rooks
hanging here you've got Queen D4 coming
as well um Magnus can just play check
and take the pawn with with the Rook or
the pawn and probably that's just a game
over he's got a minute here his
opponent's Got 5 Seconds ticking down I
think we'll see the end of the game
fairly
soon maybe just
B6 okay Queen takes if Knight there
there's Queen C2 and The Rook is uh is
hanging and then we we take back and
okay this is uh just everything hanging
at once
here and queen takes G3 and Rook e one
coming next game over but guys there's
like nine people who are going to get a
chance to play the world champion in uh
in this tournament which is which is
pretty nice let's uh let's take a look
at the standings uh meanwhile the next
game we have to look at is uh third
seated elage Safari he's also in this
tournament playing Black here and
against Alexander Lenderman he looks to
be begging for a draw here although the
time situation makes me feel like he's
probably going to earn it but he's got
to play King D5 and go for it um the
standings guys we have um who's in first
Magnus Carlson Fabiano Carana Wesley so
all three out of three and we do have a
lot of strong players on 2 and A2 but
grandmas elect aach Andra also three out
of three and still lots of games to play
in this round so we'll keep you guys uh
we'll keep you guys
updated Knight
F4 and jeez actually it's uh it's why do
has to be careful about losing this
game so Black's going to go take this
Pawn but he also has to be careful this
Pawn marching up the board yeah I uh I
definitely take that back I think it's
uh is it going to be this and then push
the pawns and play Knight C3 or he has
he has Knight D6 Knight F7 that's what
he's he's going to
do and we might see a draw here
from o no we won't see a draw maybe oh
this is going to be very very close this
is going to be very close cuz White's
King's just going to attack this Knight
um if you can get the knight in front of
the Pawn on on A2 or A3 then uh there's
there's nothing you can do black has to
play King E4 in that position there you
go there you go King E4 only move King
F5 and King
F6 and meanwhile stop this Pawn with
Knight A2 yeah A3 King F6 okay we he he
earned his draw there um butth that was
actually pretty close if if you didn't
have that Tempo move in order to play
King E4 I'd actually be very very
worried there's uh there's a chance that
you could actually lose that okay this
will be a draw though just wait for
these guys to agree on it um meanwhile
Let's uh check out the games in progress
that game is going to finish Let's
uh check out um Grandmaster Bobby Hess
here you guys know him from chess.com
definitely you've seen him uh maybe in
my position doing some commentary before
um and he's here with honestly a just a
lost position that he's probably going
to resign right now unfortunately
against uh sjov from Russia who converts
uh on a nice game with white
unfortunately Rob Robert H goes down
um and we're getting close to the the
end of this round next round guys
there's going to be some fireworks you
got way too many strong players on
perfect scores so I'm pretty
excited oo Bishop F3 this one looks like
going to be an upset here as one of the
last games in the round Vladimir hamii
looks like oh thought he was going down
and black just blunders he's up a rook
here and he's not converting oh
man well you can still play this on with
black but uh honestly I'm probably more
worried that he's going to
lose Rook A4 yeah okay maybe maybe just
take this so uh we end the misery I'm
probably more worried that Black's going
to lose than white to be
honest this looks like it's going to be
a long one I'm going to leave this on my
screen oh there was Bishop D5 there if
you wanted to just draw the
game I'm going to leave this on the
screen this is my prediction for longest
game of the
round um mvl Carana Magnus and Wesley so
all with perfect scores so look forward
to some big matchups in the next round
I'm quite sure we're going to see at
least one or
two cat rocket moo that's a good
question I will uh I will check that for
you
this game is going to go the distance it
looks like uh two out of three they're
cat rocket moo I'm not sure if that's a
result of two draws or a loss so I can't
say for sure but uh we have the chasper
on two out of three and uh I think
Nakamura is is also on two out of three
if he's if he's still in the uh in the
event otherwise uh he he may have left
left after his round I'm not too sure
but nakur also dropped a game so
definitely a lot of room to come back in
a tournament like this but with so many
people boasting perfect scores I think
that the the winner of this title
Tuesday is going to have a very very
high score um I would say at least eight
points is uh is
needed okay this this isn't necessarily
game of the round but it's definitely
longest game of the round
I don't think White's in any danger to
to lose with with a position like this
um probably hoping that his low rated
opponent actually messes up
first it is black playing for the win
but when you look at the ratings and the
fact that black was up a rook and hung
an entire night and you just feel that
anything could
happen
I can't wait for the next round though I
cannot wait um there's even more guys
joining with perfect scores here you
have shaposhnikov you have gen L uh a
lot of strong Russian Grand Masters um
International Master aan who's um quite
likely streaming right now I'm not sure
but uh he's he's even on a perfect score
as well Kanan who uh I've seen all the
time playing on live chess and Daniel
nitzki as well on a perfect score so
quite the uh the big names here uh on
perfect
scores next round should be very intense
and I think this is the last game of the
round let me confirm yes it is the last
game of the round my prediction was uh
my prediction was
right that this would be the last game I
mean
yeah there has to be a 50 move rule here
somewhere I
bet King
H4 not sure what the idea would be here
maybe check King
G3 don't hang don't hang this move
that's going to be my prediction that
this move could get uh
could get hung in this position I feel
like there's a good chance black flags
or something I got to be careful here
that's a good move that's a good
move he wants to play King F4 and uh and
go Rook to
[Music]
H1 I guess it's uh it's definitely
possible to win this end game this is
looking extremely scary
now Rook is coming to H1 white better
claim a a draw or something
oh this is
over oh
yikes that was uh honestly a just
probably just a very bad final defense
there um because that end game certainly
should be a draw but um yikes that is a
that is a heartbreaker for white to lose
that so Kudos actually to uh abdalaziz M
from is that the uh wow country of Sudan
fiday Master congratulations for that
technique because that uh did not look
winning to me all right guys we're going
to uh take a break from following Magnus
Carlson just for this round because we
have to bring you some of the biggest
matchups and we have to have to pay
attention to this one let's go guys
Fabiano Carana against Grandmaster
Wesley so this is the all ameran
battle and uh both guys on three out of
three
I'm pretty excited so we're we're
sticking with this game for this round
guys and Carana you got to make a move
my friend come on
buddy let's not uh have this super
important match just uh come down to a
flag maybe he's given
timeouts oh man I would hate for uh all
the hype for this match to be decided by
an internet problem or something maybe
Carana is getting a drink
oh come on come on Carana come back
buddy we need you
here just make it make it into a Time
odds game come back at exactly 2
minutes to be honest guys if I missed
maybe like 50 seconds of my game against
Wesley so I would probably start playing
exactly at 2 minutes so I would pretend
like oh I'm just giving time ODS um but
it looks here unfortunately like Carana
is
actually not here what's uh
what's going on
here well I won't to I want to bore you
guys with commentary on a position
that's uh
non-existent that would be uh that would
be pretty crazy but guys this is uh this
is really too
bad I think he's I think he's not here
maybe he didn't think the next round
would start so soon or he's having
internet issues but his internet
connection says on on the screen here
that it's fantastic
so jeez that's uh that's too
bad well I don't think we can stay with
this game too long I'm going to start up
uh some of the other big matchups that
we have um let's take a look at mvl
playing aan here from Ireland the big uh
big matchup here as well between um I'd
say a pretty big rating uh rating
disparity here mvl definitely the heavy
favorite but um ason a definitely a a
guy very known in the streaming
community so sure he has a lot of
support as well I'm going to keep
checking on this uh Wesley Soul
game see if he gets awarded the
point I'm sure Wesley so has got to be
pretty happy with that oo already the
bishop pair for white that's not what
you want to get give to your higher
rated
opponent those guys know what to do with
the pair of
Bishops we might see a we might see a
flag in in karan's
games don't think that he's moved
against Wesley
so let me uh let me drop in on that game
just to double check oh we're good we're
just going to drop in on the flag
that's oh
man that's crazy
never before seen guys oh man so we
don't even see the the big matchup that
that we wanted to see well there you go
guys the All-American battle goes to
Grandmaster Wesley so he showed some
nice preparation there um that was a
riveting one let's take uh take a glance
back at mv's game which I'm hoping will
uh you know uh maybe last a little bit
longer maybe a few more moves than
that but that was uh that was actually a
crazy game guys um Wesley just showing
some some great technique but uh mostly
just Fab's time management once again uh
becoming an issue that's probably the
only reason he lost there is mostly just
on time so tough tough game but uh I I
know I was you know glued to the edge of
my seat for the All-American
battle two Bishops here for mvl I always
personally like to play pay very close
attention to um these matchups because
it's uh it's always really nice to watch
what a strong player can do with a pair
of Bishops um definitely definitely
something to to pay very close attention
to from from a learning standpoint I'll
say so uh what we'll see is black trying
to basically uh use the the light Square
blockade here and I'm sure that the move
Bishop F1 is going to be played at some
point I also uh feel like the move
Bishop E1 and maybe KN E4 is uh is
coming as
well but black wants to put a knight on
C4 so we'll probably see this move
Bishop
E1 and Bishop F1 or maybe just Bishop F1
so Knight B6 I think is the only move
here otherwise the the blockade fails
and the C C6 Pawn is simply too weak
so takes takes oo I don't I don't
approve of that I know it's opposite
Bishops here but uh take a look at those
pawns guys all on light squares for that
light squar Bishop to uh to n Nom on and
meanwhile this Pawn chain seems very
effective in blocking this bishop so
Knight's going to go to D3 we might see
doubling the doubling the Rooks which is
uh ironic here playing the uh playing
the guy from Ireland and White's the one
doing the Dublin um but we might might
see that being the most effective
strategy here Knight going to B4 double
the Rooks Bishop to G2 and I really like
the pressure that mvl can create against
this weak Pawn this backwards Pawn that
uh we have on C6
here Black's putting pressure on D4 but
you have to R Wonder exactly what his
plan is it's it's going to be E5 but as
long as white s steps E5 uh tactically
along the dile then I don't uh I don't
think that there's going to be that much
of an issue
here so it doesn't look like it's going
to be that bad um for for white without
E5 I don't see the counterplay for for
black this guy is a Sitting Duck you
know you're going to see slow moves to
improve the position Bishop to uh F3
King G2 um eventually Knight B4 maybe
Rook C2 but um aan is holding uh holding
in there he's definitely holding in
there but o unless it's some counter
flight involving Knight takes G3 or
something there maybe bishop F6 and G5
and then try to play
H4 that's my
recommendation but jeez that C6 Pawn is
simply falling and that was inevitable
we we knew that was
coming many moves
ago I wonder if he's thinking about
something along the lines of you know a
queen takes G3 after a bishop gets to D4
and he does he does take that and this
is the only counterplay that that he's
going to go for and Rook takes D4 um and
that unleashes Queen G3 it unleashes the
idea of Bishop takes with check so it
definitely feels uh maybe a little crazy
in this position King H2 Rook takes H4
for example but uh I wouldn't be
surprised if there was a a refutation
let's let's be careful though this is a
really nice uh really nice practical
idea by estan whether or not it works I
love what he just did the only weakness
in white structure as I was saying was
those dark squares and okay Queen E1
seems to protect the Pawn get out of the
uh the pin there and what is the idea
with
that I don't get that
one but unfortunately guys Knight C6 was
coming so there you go that's the best I
can say about that I do like the move uh
that he played there he's probably going
to play G5 now followed by H4 um I like
what he did there but like I was saying
White's position was so good that it
would be sort of bizarre to me if all of
a sudden he was losing by some sequence
like that um in chess you know it's a
pretty fair game things don't deserve to
work that way so if your position is
good it's pretty rare that you know just
out of the blue this tactical sequence
will pop
up okay just trade that Rook though
trade that Rook on d8 and the queen
wants to come to G5 or h8 and then H2
but the King on F1 after Queen H2 check
is also completely safe so still a bit
of a job for conversion purposes to do
here but I know Rook up for mvl uh you
got to feel confident in the guy King G1
and King F1 is completely safe after
Queen H2 so I don't think he's worried
about that check at all Queen takes B4
here is the better move there we go and
mv's got to be careful the more pawns he
loses uh suddenly the harder it is to
win but uh I think what he should do is
something like Bishop well not now but
something like getting a king to G2 with
a a rook coming to H1 maybe Queen
F3 can we do Bishop takes A4
there Queen E4 I don't see I don't see
the point of that but Black's very low
on time
so he's trying to hang in there down an
entire Rook against mvl that's not the
easiest thing to
do not the easiest thing to
do yikes well guys um it looks like mvl
is going to get the victory let me
update you on the standings because it's
uh really close at the top another um
big thing we have to mention is Magnus
Carlson four out of four unfortunately
Fabiano Carana just you know didn't move
against Wesley so which is unprecedented
in um in these title Tuesday events I
don't think I've seen that especially
from such a a strong player you know
like of course they're going to be here
for their games on time so that's really
too bad we didn't see that big match up
but Wesley so perfect score four out of
four mvl we just saw his victory four
out of four Daniel nitzki perfect score
mag Carlson perfect score and the two
yenis Levan and shaposhnikov from Russia
both moving a four out of four U and
there's definitely a group a pack
chasing them um afterwards but
uh for the moment those are the perfect
scores so let's uh take a look here as
the the round goes on we have Eric
Hansen here potentially is that a losing
end game um he's hoping for a draw here
and and we have to watch out for this
threat um the king comes down and when
The Rook goes over here actually we have
this move as well so okay he's going to
transition into to this end game which
is definitely drawn and we'll basically
see if uh if black makes a major blender
in this end game but with 12 uh seconds
on the clock I don't see I don't see
there being any issues here for um for
black making a draw this for most uh
most grand Masters just very routine uh
I talked about this actually in an
earlier position from the title Tuesday
where we had a filor filor position
defense so I think we're going to see a
draw right here don't imagine that uh
White's going to be playing on there it
is draw on the board um and that is the
no not the last game but very close to
it in uh in this fourth
round Queen G8 and actually it looks
like black has the only chances to win
here with all of the pieces against the
queen and and yes Rook takes B2 is
coming that's very scary I think black
is just completely winning and maybe
we'll see Queen takes rook and then take
back and he'll have to do a a bishop and
knight checkmate maybe we'll see that oh
I don't like this I don't like this at
all just Rook D2 or Rook
B3 yeah this this doesn't feel very
convincing Oh that's oh at least he
should have sacked his Queen for The
Rook make him do a bishop and Knight but
we're definitely appreciative of that
game not going very long so we can get
right into the action in round five um
let's see what the matchups are because
again we could get some really really
big matchups here we're all waiting for
maybe Wesley so against Magnus Carlson
but I think we might need a few more
rounds before we get that and we do um
let's take a look at Magnus Carlson this
might be the the most important match of
this round Magnus Carlson here still in
a perfect score in his first title
Tuesday event and he's playing the black
pieces against Daniel nitzki who has won
this uh this event before a very
dangerous guy and Blitz in general but
also in this tournament he has
consistently performed very
well the commentator just woke up
actually that's not true but uh maybe
maybe my hair looks like it I I can
accept those comments I can accept those
comments uh not true but uh
I I hope my commentary doesn't sound
like it's sleepy as well that's that's
the main thing we see a sideline here
from Magnus Carlson there we go why why
does that not surprise us because um
sometimes when you're at a raing
discrepancy against still a very strong
player you want to make a point that uh
you don't want to go into necessarily
the mainline Theory um because that
might might be too easy for the uh for
your opponent to play so it seems he
he's maybe playing a subpar system just
to get out of opening Theory uh but
Bishop G5 and uh probably going to see
C5
here I guess uh Bishop B4 check is
certainly possible but after C5 uh the
move must be C3 and white gets a a nice
looking initiative here unless I think
we might see the move D3 that feels the
most
principled D3 is a tough Pawn to
recapture and even if you do the
material is only equal um I I I feel
like taking with takes and and night
takes with long Castle coming in that
feels like a great Initiative for white
to have in this position so um will we
see you know one of the
first real games
where Magnus Carlson could get in
trouble and I see aaro in the chat
um and I and I think that uh like I wasp
exp ing there were some internet issues
for Hikaru uh some some maybe connection
issues um and unfortunately he's uh he's
not in the tournament anymore uh for
that reason so we're we're sad to see
him go after after a tough loss earlier
on but uh it looks like we're going to
have to uh we're have going to keep our
fingers crossed for the the big matchups
between potentially Fabby uh if he's
back in the tournament I should say he
also maybe is having some connection
issues so um a lot of the top players um
having a few problems but that doesn't
stop us from keeping the show going on
and uh we still have some of the
strongest players in the world still
here battling it out and um getting back
to this game between Magnus Carlson and
Daniel nitzki it looks like uh somehow
let me just go back what did he do queen
E7 Queen E7 so he found a creative way
here White's missing is dark light
squared Bishop so uh what we're seeing
here is black trying to play exclusively
on the light squares and after Knight D5
white can castle and you know trading
Queens is not ideal You're simply down a
pawn here stops Rook C3 stops Rook C7
attacks E3 and these Knights just have
no power against this queen so even uh
some knight move or queen E2 whatever it
is Black's more than happy to trade
Queens like I said he's up a pawn bishop
D6 coming two Bishops everything is
aligning for black here and what looked
like maybe a difficult opening is uh
shaping up to be um potentially
potentially uh an an easy game for
Magnus Carlson will'll be see I was
going to say we'll be see C6 but Knight
takes E3 play so probably F takes
E3 Queen takes there is a risky option I
mean there's Knight G2 in the position I
don't don't imagine
um don't imagine will'll see that move
that looks a bit risky F takes E3 is
played the safer
version this is the uh this is the more
principled way but unfortunately if
basically guys if white could Castle I
would say white has a decent initiative
there but look how easily black is able
to get castled here meanwhile white is
not not able to do so himself and King
F2 even drops a piece so let's say black
Castle here what what does white do
check you just tuck the King on h8
everything seems is protected there's no
discovered attacks or anything black is
up a pawn he's got the two Bishops
against the two knights unfortunately
this game looked interesting at the
start but Magnus really really took over
command
here Magnus really took over command I
won't be surprised to see him try to
keep the Bishops with a move like that
but then there follows Knight E4 so uh
the simplification might be preferable
takes takes Queen D1 um H but he's
looking for more he is looking for
tactics rookie
8 yikes he's looking to punish white for
his setup here with this weak Pawn like
that and the King's still in the middle
Magnus is going for tactics Rook to E8
King F2 of course we hang this piece
right
there I'm wondering what I can uh
suggest here for white very tough
position Queen there um not King there
guys because we will hang Our Queen 296
check so a little tra Maybe maybe last
ditch effort um but Bishop E6 played
Queen F3 and now we're going to see this
bishop move somewhere Bishop C4
probably Bishop C4 looks uh like a nice
move remember the Knight is pinned and
there's still The Rook takes E3 threat
and Bishop there feels really nice
threatening some sort of checkmates on
F1 or E2 but he he goes Bishop B3 which
looks to be a similar effect black is
totally winning here on top of
everything that I'm saying the the
bottom line is white cannot Castle cuz
white could even give up some material
here and have some initiative on the f
file but the the fact that white can't
Castle means it's very difficult to set
something like that up there's going to
be Rook takes or Bishop takes on E3 next
turn if Knight B3 just Bishop E3 and
queen B3 that's over that is game over
the queen even covers the diagonal to
the king so we might even see a
resignation there we go very quick game
by Magnus we've just seen Domination by
him in this title Tuesday so far let's
take a look at Wesley so who we haven't
actually seen in action so
far let's check
Wesley there it
is so Wesley so
um interesting is this uh is this game
live for some reason they not looks a
little
funny maybe that's not a live game let's
try it again I'm having trouble loading
Wesley's game for some
reason this guy sounds so tired I can't
understand him I uh I have been up for
up for a while I'm trying not to sound
too tired I think I have a lot of energy
I've definitely had most energy in this
title Tuesday for any any single one
that I've commentated and I've done
quite a few by now I'm having trouble
loading uh Wesley's game I wonder why
yeah that's very
strange for some reason I can't load
Wesley's game right now so we're going
to have to uh we're going to have to
take a look at uh his game afterwards or
hopefully the next round lows a little
easier for now this is mvl playing Black
against y 11 this is a battle of two
guys with perfect scores and the game
was drawn so we actually don't have any
perfect scores except Magnus and we are
waiting for um a few games to finish
that could affect that so let's go to
one of the other games which can affect
that and that is the game between
definitely an underdog here uh I should
say two underdogs both of these guys on
perfect scores um you know having the uh
Tournament of their lives perhaps I
don't know who they've beaten up till
now double click it is being
suggested let me
try double click
double click is not working for me
unfortunately I will try again after
after this game um this should be a draw
for sure but we are going to see white
uh play
on and I say for sure this should be a
draw but the more that I look at it
actually that might have been a mistake
by me because white can can create a
pass Pawn on the f file I I actually
thought that this was even material on
the king side but whites up two pawns
here so this should actually be winning
this should be winning there's no way
you can take that Pawn because of uh the
queening idea so this bishop needs to
sort of reroute out of there so the king
can try to come in and once King B5 is
played Black has to play King to B6 or
D6 and then white can play F4 so I
imagine bring the bishop out play King
B5 and then start to play
F4 so this is a battle of two 24
6070s um who are clearly overperforming
this tournament imagine but but one of
them if if one of them wins could have a
perfect score along with Magnus Carlson
that might even be a pairing for next
round so keep these names in mind
because I imagine that the winner here
oh now we can play we can't play Bishop
takes that's
important we can't play Bishop takes so
what some Bishop bishop move and
threaten
F4 oh sorry excuse me that's not uh
prevented A7 is covered by the uh the
bishop but that's only uh that's only
momentary basically we can use uh this
Pawn as a decoy now just play F6 F7 when
the King goes to get it then you bring
your king into
C6 he'll bring that Bishop all the way
back yep play King B5 King D6 and play
F6 and then the King has to go take that
pawn and you march your king in there
and you put this bishop on H5 and that
that should be a draw excuse me that
should be a win what am I saying that
should be a
win yep so maybe maybe do the the bishop
move first you want to be careful that
you don't end up yeah Bishop there
Bishop E8 Bishop H5 so just Bishop E8
first and then A7 I
like A7
first okay no difference Bishop E8
Bishop h 5 and run your king over that's
that's an easy win guys that's an easy
win an update Wesley so has
lost that looks like a big result as
Wesley
lost oh man Wesley so lost a game I I
mean he's never lost a a classical game
that it's just insane really to uh to
see him lose a Blitz game um I wonder
who he was who he was playing let me
check the uh the list I think he's
playing ygi
shaposhnikov um who actually does really
really well in these uh in these
tournaments just mud I see your comment
you you definitely don't need to spam
definitely don't need to spam
um Yani shash got five out of five guys
that's quite impressive five out of five
for sarov he just beat Wesley so I mean
nobody's done that classical chess for
like what over 50 games that's that's
what the stat is Right Wesley has gone
52 games or something without a loss
which is uh pretty incredible here and
we do see uh agar 94 Fay master from
Brazil um I'm being told he hasn't
played a GM yet so maybe he hasn't met
his match but five out of five is still
an impressive start no matter how you
get there um and let's take a look at
the all GM battle allamerican o sorry I
thought that said mner Mackenzie mner
but mourner 1951 I'm not sure who that
Grandmaster is that's Croatia and ooh
nice we're seeing a bishop Knight
technique here by uh Grandmaster hes
Bishop to
B4 let's see the uh oops the technique
Knight back bishop move Knight check
Bishop mate and there it is finally
we're getting a nice clean uh nice clean
bishop and Knight mate it's funny I
think we see a bishop and knight
checkmate every single title Tuesday or
at least everyone I've done I can uh I
can remember them very
vividly okay
so let's uh go to the standings guys
because once again we have this fiday
master 2470 ahead of Magnus here or tied
at least with Five Points there's three
guys with perfect scores soshnikov agar
94 from Brazil and Grandmaster Magnus
Carlson of course and then we have uh GI
gen 11 we have Safari mvl those guys are
at
42 and then we have a group of people
chasing with with four points and quite
a few names there that you guys are
going to recognize for sure um but the
next round which is underway now is
going to
feature some very big matchups and let
me uh head over there for the first time
let's take a look at Grand Master Wesley
so in action because Wesley so and mvl
is a huge uh matchup Magnus is playing
the feay master we were going to let him
handle business and if we get a quick
draw here we'll go check that out but I
think uh we haven't really paid
attention to Wesley so's games so far so
we definitely have to uh show him that
respect and against nvl that this is by
far the the match of the round for
sure so we see what we could classify as
maybe slightly boring stuff but I wonder
if if these guys are going to make a
draw or if we're going to see this
slight Advantage for white that you
always get from these positions uh
actually materialize into something uh I
would say this is the least likely
position that Wesley is going to lose
from I don't know what position he lost
against soshnikov or how he managed to
do that but Wesley is almost the guy
that you you figure will never lose a
game um so maybe maybe his time
management or his ability to play
quickly is is what's costing him because
we've seen in classical the guy is just
unbeatable if he doesn't want to lose he
knows what openings to choose um he's a
very safe player doesn't take too many
risks so that's the that's the kind of
guy you want on your uh on your fantasy
football team um the guy who's uh always
going to always going to produce some
points all right so um Wesley so against
uh
mvl um Magnus Carlson is still playing
as an update for uh those wondering
whether he won in like 5 seconds or
something he is playing an FM who is at
five out of five but uh still it doesn't
doesn't mean it's an easy game uh by any
stretch Magnus is white so I feel like
he has a big Advantage there but uh this
is definitely materializing into quite a
uh quite a serious uh grind I would say
I would probably trade the Bishops here
although the other thing is that trading
B shishs does favor Black because uh he
has a little bit less space for his
pieces white if he does have an
advantage it's got to be space and maybe
development for a little bit um but
that's going to go away it's a very
temporary Advantage we call it um
development lead and development stuff
like that that's a very temporary
Advantage material is obviously a
permanent uh
Advantage but this is uh this is
something that I feel we're uh maybe
going to leave just for the moment
because I have a feeling this is uh is
going to be fairly equal moving forward
but I like to move F4 I think is that
going to cause him to take or maybe take
and play Queen
F6 yeah I like to move
F4 there we
go okay maybe Knight to
G6 or if not Knight G6 then if the
Knight moves black plays Queen D6 Bishop
F7 I think he's completely fine Knight
G6 I had the idea to take back and
threaten F5 while trying to stop Bishop
F7 with having my Bishop there um
although it doesn't look entirely
reasonable let's check out magnus's game
ooh No we're going to stay here tactic
time Knight takes C6 and
F5 is that just missed by by Wesley I
it's not that you necessarily lose more
material there because after Pawn takes
of course you do get it back with Queen
takes but that end game is got to be
good for white this is a bad Pawn
structure
and was Knight takes F7 possible there
um asks Martin Bo Knight takes
F7 Knight takes F7 possible uh there's a
knight here which is defending the
bishop if that's what you
meant yeah and Knight takes n no I don't
think there was a knight F7 but Knight
C6 maybe the same sort of tactic you
were talking about we might see Wesley
draw this but that uh that is definitely
an advantage for uh for mvl in this end
game you're going to play moves like G3
King E3 maybe Knight A5 put pressure on
this yeah King
D6 and we might see B4 there it is y got
to got to have
B4 I appreciate that uh twice nightly
but uh yeah you've got uh you got a
couple ways you can put up with me
material l ODS doing some chess bra
shows and uh doing a little commentary
for title Tuesday as always so I hope
you guys are hope you guys are enjoying
it Knight is going to C5 here and I'm
going to stay with this game guys
because I uh I really have to give
credit to mvl for pushing in this
position he's down a minute on the clock
so take back everything I said about
Wesley playing slow he is clearly
playing fast enough um and it looks like
the only way he's losing here is on
positions so mvl pushing for Victory I
think the likely result is a draw but um
these pawns are actually dominated by
this light Square Bishop for the moment
and we'll see if the time becomes a
factor I think that's the main thing is
Bishop F5 an idea here to take maybe
with the pawn and play play
B5 maybe that's uh maybe that's an idea
I see magnus's game is done oh Magnus
won update guys Magnus won he is at 6
out of six I mean are we going to see
Magnus win with uh nine out of nine what
do you guys think you guys you guys let
me know because I have commentated one
title Tuesday where Alexander bordnick
uh Blackhorse 96 on chess.com he
actually
won with nine out of nine it was the
first and I believe the only title
Tuesday ever to finish with nine out of
nine and um that was insane at the time
but could we see a Repeat Performance
here by Mangus wson three rounds to go
you know guys like Fabiano Carana and
Nakamura are not in the tournament and
you know looking at the list there's not
that many guys here who are going to
pose very serious problems to to Magnus
mvl has to keep winning in order to do
that and so does Wesley so but Wesley
has four points mvl has four and a half
Magnus is already at six right now so
these guys have to step it up if uh if
they're going to try to win the uh win
the event or at least challenge Magnus
most people say eight eight out of nine
that was my initial prediction not
necessarily Magnus but I said the winner
would have to have eight points that's
definitely clear um but the other the
other thing to keep in mind is that uh
basically if Wesley so and mvl don't uh
you know tie their tie their skates up
nice and tight Canadian hockey skates
and uh start trying to do some catchup
here then we're not we're not going to
see the big matchups that are going to
keep Magnus from winning 9-0 so I think
there's a very reasonable chance guys
that we see a 90 here from Magnus I
think Wesley has more or less secured
his draw there's no way to to break
through here in fact you can even play
the move A6 but uh no I think Wesley has
demonstrated that he actually is the
only one playing for a win in this
position because he has the potential to
play the move F5 and white hasn't really
got anything here we might just see a
repetition um but black is the one
playing for anything uh if at all
because these pawns are neutralized over
here guys this this is three pawns
holding back four pawns so mvl really
let this end game slip in my opinion
black is the one playing for the king
side now so Wesley so if he wins that's
very big he's got four points right now
he needs this win to catch up to Magnus
I think that's without a doubt what are
we waiting for where is this
move what are we waiting for here I
wonder why he doesn't want to play that
so takes takes you know maybe a move
like this you always have King D6 or
Knight D7 so it looks safe is he just
teasing here is he going to play back
yeah he does so Bishop A4 yeah but now
how do you play F5 it's not so
easy now it's not so easy King D7 Bishop
C2 and now King E6 Bishop A4 and we
might see a repetition there
interesting okay it's it's weird to me
that he he's not too worried about
F5 uh and I'm kind of wondering why I
think he's going to
do I think he's going to do nothing
maybe just sit there and let F4 happen
he's going to take I don't know this
seems uh seems like definitely possible
for black to win and Wesley here has got
a huge time Advantage MV has like six
seconds counting down black just takes
this Pawn plays Knight D6 uh H5 G4 you
got to be so careful here not to lose
with white um I think mvl should should
have been going for a
draw jeez H5 yeah Bishop G6
no I think Bishop G6 was important
there Bishop
G6 I think Wesley should be trying to
play for a win but I just don't I'm not
getting the ambition Vibe I don't feel
like he wants to do
it Knight F5 King F3 and the move C4 is
coming but the Knight is attacking D4 at
the
moment guys I'm just not sure if uh mvl
is is clear which result he's playing
for so he's bringing the Knight to F6
enel looks like he's clearly asking for
a draw by just repeating but the Knight
on F6 covers H5 and now the King can
March over to C6 B6 A5 and we do see the
move C4 before that can
happen uh this looks more and more
drawish King
E3 King E7 Bishop C4 King D6 Bishop F7
maybe a draw like
that I don't think uh I don't think that
white is going to lose this one anymore
yeah King E3
and if black wants to create a pass Pawn
that's fine but but there doesn't seem
to be any way that that this position
will be will be losing he's trying
though I I respect that so King E3 King
B4 what is it Bishop E2 Bishop E6 much
better of
course and King there then you really
risk letting the pawn run you have to be
careful with that and notice how white
is not playing D5 black wants the dark
squares with King C5 so he's not going
to let that happen Bishop B6 do not play
Knight D5 and and lose the game there
King B6 Wesley wants to win look at that
he has declined multiple multiple draws
in order to play for a win
here King
D6 King B6
no I think he's going for a draw
now but you have to uh you have to at
least admire the effort Wesley so from a
worst position it looked like uh maybe
he missed a tactic earlier I'm not sure
but um he was never down material and he
was always way up on the clock so he
actually ended up pressing in this uh
final position but couldn't uh couldn't
come out with the Victory and neither
could mvl so guys what what does this
mean for Magnus Carlson he's sitting on
six out of six and mvl is now at Five
Points and Wesley still at four and a
half so he's just uh closing out huge
lead over the competition now he's got
Yen 11 at 5 and a half elch Safari also
at 5 and a half that he has to uh be
very careful of but other than that he
he really doesn't have to worry about
some of the top top guys in this
tournament it looks
like I wonder why he's not playing
G4 G4 Bishop takes and then E2 what hang
on a sec why not
G4 I I'll just I guess I'll keep
following the game but uh G4 Bishop
takes and then E2 King takes
I mean G4 I might play King E2 but then
King G3
and looks like it's also winning so
maybe he's just getting more time on the
clock but uh where is G4 here no no hang
on a sec are we missing
something oh is that is that really nice
yeah guys that's really
nice guys look at that King takes
F4 and now E2 G3 check and if the king
moves Bishop takes and then takes on E2
and that is a losing
position
oo I don't think anybody saw that I see
a lot of people uh suggesting King E2
but uh no that that doesn't work G4 King
takes F4 even if you insert Bishop B8
check when my King's on F4 King takes E3
and you're you're losing all your Pawns
there so G4 King takes F4 is actually
really really nice um and credit to both
players who it looks like they both saw
that so actually if you go for that all
of a sudden you might even lose by uh by
trying to play G4 there with black so
very very uh careful not to play that
was uh Jack snipe which I believe is
Grandmaster Benjamin Bach from the
Netherlands and Grandmaster Yan gooli uh
Nuki from France playing white this
looks like it's going to be the last
game of the Round Here mostly just
shuffling now King F3 King E2 I don't
think there's don't think there's
anything to play for
unfortunately these guys are probably
going to agree to a draw very soon and
we're going to get into what will be
round seven so only three more rounds to
go Magnus commanding lead on the
tournament uh just over the very strong
players but actually there's uh a few
people chasing him only half a point
behind um but let's say some of the top
players in the world who we
definitely expected to do very well in
in this
tournament are either probably too far
behind Magnus to catch him or uh or just
not not in the top top standings which
is good news for Magnus Carlson so let's
get into it guys that was the last game
of the round now starting round seven
and Magnus Carlson against El Safari we
have to take a look at this game this is
very important game for the standings
Magnus doesn't mind giving up draws but
let's just take a moment guys and take a
look at Magnus Carlson's Blitz rating
2990 I mean he could hit 3,000 if he
wins the rest of the games of this
tournament that is certainly true in
Blitz by the way 3,000 in Blitz that is
unheard of uh and it would be totally
deserved if he went 9 and0 in this
tournament cuz that's very hard to do
even for the best player play in the
world so for the tournament standings
he's very okay with the draw here elj
Safari chasing with 5 and a half points
behind Magnus Carlson at six so this is
still uh anybody's game if Magnus
Carlson loses the floodgates open up but
2990 is a it's a pretty ridiculous
rating so let's see uh let's see what he
can do um other matchups we have
shimanov uh also closing the distance uh
a lot of people have five points I'll
say in this tournament um quite a lot of
people have five points Wesley so only
has 4 and a half out of six so he
actually needs to win the rest of the
games to even probably have a Podium
finish um but in the meantime let's
stick with this game of Magnus Carlson
let me just check the opening okay so a
Berlin um although not uh not
necessarily the main lines of the Berlin
but I think Magnus is uh is quite versed
here we're going to see knight uh Knight
E6 most
likely not sure if there is another move
then Knight E6 maybe B6 A6
interesting A6 and if Bishop takes
Knight of course we can take back and
attack the queen and if Bishop takes
here then I guess we could take
on take on B5 that seemed uh oops that
is not a uh move that was played that
seemed uh a bit weird to me Bishop takes
C5
here is there uh ah Bishop takes C5 runs
into this some queen move and then if
the queen takes Bishop A6 so that's what
I was wondering about why why wasn't
that maybe a free Pawn so Bishop E2 D6
and giving up the bishop pair was elage
Safari and Magnus Carlson seems to have
gotten the bishop pair every single game
so far I don't I don't know how he does
it are we we're going to see a queen
exchange I think that's almost
forced no well okay if not the the two
Bishops are very happy here basically
this is like a Berlin except black got a
chance to get castled and uh these two
Bishops look favorable white has the
kingside pawn majority but uh two
Bishops in an open position like this
definitely got to be feeling
good Whit's or sorry blacks looking to
play B5 next uh White might play some
sort of structure like this but
essentially rookie one and bring the
king to the center is what needs to
happen this Pawn also looks potentially
weak after Rook E8 and maybe bishop f8
or something so something uh a little
something for Magnus Carlson it looks
like um I don't think he'll be unhappy
with this
position taking a look uh at the
standings it looks like y l has agreed
to a draw with his opponent um I'm not
sure who it was
actually or maybe he maybe he won
actually he has six out of seven so he
finished his game very very quickly um
he's now tied for the lead but of course
there's still games to play
F4
F6 and we might just see an equal equal
position um I always prefer the the two
Bishops but uh now that I'm looking at
this aren't there a few tactics here
yeah G4 is the only move I think and
we'll we see no not Bishop C8 because
then that's a hanging Pawn
but takes takes and okay this might be
just a a boring draw not necessarily
boring but definitely quick takes
takes and there's no he's not going to
play Rook d8 is he is he going to play
Rook d8 actually he could rook
d8 and Rook D2 oh he's not going to okay
I think we might see a draw offer uh
fairly soon um or Magnus might play it
on because uh he will win this Pawn on
on E5 by playing King E6 but the reason
that I'm saying it should be a draw is
uh that's a
bit yeah now the reason I'm saying it
should be a draw is because you can be
down pawns um in these opposite color
Bishop positions and and it's still
still
drawn so this one looks like it's going
to be a draw and then Magnus moves to 6
and2 still in the clear lead in the
tournament nobody can catch him I
believe yeah I believe that was
soshnikov and Levan who agreed to ad
draw so nobody can catch Magnus in terms
of points for going into the next
round and maybe he's pushing slightly
but of course this should be a
relatively routine
draw D take on B4 take on B4 and play
B3 and then Bishop
E4 okay well let's check out another
game guys I have the opinion that this
should be a
draw and if I'm wrong uh then I'll
definitely have to go back to that game
let's check out mvl U BS 86 I actually
don't know who this grandmas is um but
he seems to be in a better position
against
mvl just Rook takes
E6 let's check maybe what happen in the
opening there we go I was going to say
there must have been some fire on the
board Knight takes E6 Queen G6 ooh long
castle and queen H5 and then it looks
like some good work by Maxim to somehow
trade the Queens off and just really get
back into this game that what I'm
looking at right now guys whites up a
pawn in an end game but this game looks
like uh it could have been over in the
opening
maybe draw greed in Carlson's game there
we go so Magnus retains his half point
lead on the rest of the field elaj
Safari and evi L are chasing with six
out of seven points only two rounds to
go though so Magnus probably needs about
a point and a half to
um to claim victory in this tournament
so it won't be a nine out of nine
performance by him but there's potential
for him still to break 3,000 I didn't
see how much rating he lost for that
draw but uh I know that El Safari is
pretty high
rated uh hooker Hikaru is is not in the
event is not in the
event white up a pawn here against mvl
pretty nice position to be in but uh
like I was just saying black has done
some tremendous work to make this
position even playable from what I saw
before so King E1 Chase The Rook out
it's important
and Rook F1 probably Rook C C8 King D2
we might check again and then go back to
C8 and Rook or sorry Knight to D1 you
also have to be careful of uh even
losing and this is a cute little
arrangement of pieces all we need is
White's Rook on e4 and Black's Rook on
E8 and then shift those pieces backwards
one square that is not a move that uh
was
played there we go C4 was
played Bishop takes G2 we missing any
tactics here maybe Knight takes and Rook
G4 yeah that looks that looks like the
best Knight takes and Rook G4 and then
depending on the Move uh you take this
or even better if we can take this Pawn
that would be fantastic that is a weird
move oh I guess he wanted this Rook
F7 that seems deep actually Bishop uh
sorry Rook G4 seem to attack the bishop
and the pawn that looks simple enough
for
me Rook F7
and G5 so we got to take this Pawn now
it seems yep check or Rook
C2 check um we can play King there but
he's deciding to play this and King Rook
C3 check no that was weird what just
happened
there maybe this is okay because you get
this Pawn but Black's not even down a
pawn here hang on a sec was this not
possible there's Che back and then you
bring the bishop back and it's the same
thing but you're just not missing your
Pawn there's this to think about but we
have the check here to to cover so I
wasn't that worried about this uh that
seems a little bit strange from from
White there I think that might have been
the wrong the wrong thing to do cuz now
black is really active and I think black
easily easily has the draw here and
we're going to see moves like uh you
know H5 H4 G4 Bishop F3 King
F4 and that is how uh that is how black
is probably going to try to play for a
win here guys all of a sudden it's it's
maybe black who's who's
pushing interesting well that's a pretty
big turnaround from what looked like uh
looked to me like maybe white was up
like a pawn or maybe even two
pawns kuu 42 I agree very cool to see
Magnus Carlson play playing publicly
first of all um oh you can take on G5
here can't you what you can take on G5
and play Rook G2 and Rook F2 that seems
weird
oh no almost almost a tactic there he's
trying to win which is which is good but
I don't think he's going to
manage maybe
G4 yeah it's great to see Magnus Carlson
here uh his first time in a title
Tuesday uh not his first time publicly
playing an online chess we had the blitz
battle but uh I mean if you're playing
in this title Tuesday event which I
would like to but it's very cool to be
uh be very cool to be uh commentating as
well because that means I get to see all
the games if you're playing you don't
get to watch magnus's games and if
you're not doing well you don't get to
play him either so actually you get to
appreciate Magnus more when you're when
you're a
commentator okay so what should we do as
white I think take followed by Rook here
cutting the king off and pushing B6 is
the easiest way to achieve what I think
is a draw um maybe use this Pawn as a
decoy because I don't I think leaving
the Bishops on the board like we can't
push this Pawn here there's there's no
way um now black just moves his Bishop
back gets his King up and I think white
is uh going to regret that decision if
here here here here Bishop F5 and then
we might be able to give Jacks and play
G5 G4
H3 he's just going for it he's pushing
the G
pawn and what are we going to play here
Bishop G2 as well covers everything oh
G2 now what about
G2 oh this is winning Rook G8 we can
even take a free Pawn here or Rook G3
might yeah Rook G3 might have been just
a very nice move there I think Rook G3
although he he knows he's winning here
so he's not too worried
Rook G6 King F7 so he's going to go
there
and oh there's almost some very nice
wins but how does he finish this off
that's a good
question okay Rook
there King there H but now Rook check
and Rook
G3 ah no he can't do that cuz it's
Bishop G2 now I think he missed his
chance Rook G3 was very clean now he's
going to have to work a little bit
harder we could also see a rook and
Bishop against Rook if uh this end game
continues the way the way that it looks
like Rook
C5 King B4 that's dangerous though you
can check and bring the Rook
back Bishop back yeah this was the
problem that your Bishop needed to be
here in order to stop my Bishop from
just moving back and now I play H3 and
it's just over just game over
yeah oh that's a nice nice technique
from mvl
there nice
technique half
crab half crab because you never see my
hands that's a fair
comment the camera angle is not
uh is not very uh conducive to to uh to
my lower
body proof that I have hands boys
proof no uh no
crab is this the last game is chess bra
is the last game guys we're following
along Eric Hansen Alexander moscalenko
Eric's playing for the win here it looks
like um but I'm actually not sure maybe
you have to be careful with a few things
but it feels like uh black is is kind of
playing for the win maybe the most
likely result as a draw Eric is
um Eric is continuing to to push here
though 20 seconds maybe if White's King
gets gets black uh then he can dream of
trying to win but I I feel like only
black can set things up here with the
potential of a pass H Pawn and the the
bishop and King work very well together
holy oh my goodness that is uh not
only oh man that's not only a bishop but
that that might be the game right there
King takes H 4 remember that's another
check G takes F5 and then takes and now
well I was saying that actually we
shouldn't say this is necessarily over
just yet this is not
over you know we have we have ideas
right there's uh H4 King there remember
this is uh the last game of the round
coming up next guys is um round eight
and that means only two more games for
for Magnus if Eric wants any chance of
uh drawing it looks like he has to keep
this uh this King cut but he's also low
on time so things aren't working uh
working in his favor
here I uh I can definitely say that okay
this and then maybe try to push the pawn
is an attempt but there's going to
follow with with Rook check and we know
this is losing so the King has to come
back and unfortunately just just bring
the king back to G2 and that's that's
going to be enough for for white
here
yeah and that is uh what it looked like
only black was pressing but then at at
the very last seconds very last
second this is
uh this is resal that's the last game of
the round
guys breaking news Lawrence trend is
going wild well that's the benefit of
actually uh having me uh do the
commentary is that you got an inside
look at uh at exactly what goes on in
the uh the chess bra cave here you know
that's just that's some raw chess
emotion right there so guys we're into
round eight we're into round eight glad
that Lawrence Trent is in the audience
and enjoying
himself uh as we do see the the raw
chess emotions coming out Magnus Carlson
who is he playing Y Gen 11 and we might
not even see him matched up against
Wesley so and this is what I was
expecting guys um there's only one more
m match after this and we haven't seen
other people keeping up the pace that
Magnus Carlson is setting
here we haven't seen anyone keep
Pace yeah that was uh that was an
unfortunate game guys unfortunate game
Magnus here playing what looks like
Queen's Indian yeah Queen's
Indian Knight E4 um with the tournament
situation with black here I'm sure that
uh he's okay with the draw although he's
definitely not playing for one let's say
um but a draw would be a completely fine
result for black here um he would have
white going into the last round with
very good chances to to play for a win
so we might might see takes and Bishop
E4 Bishop E4 is uh is a standard idea in
these kind of positions uh you put the
bishop there and I think it might be a
little too early for what I'm suggesting
but the idea is to put the bishop there
and then it means that if this knight
ever moves you're happy to trade and it
stops white from playing E4 permanently
until that
happens so are we going to see Knight D7
or F5 F5 is the way to really prevent E4
so now we're going to see takes and
Knight D7 it looks like Knight D7 and
Knight F6 doesn't look like that much to
complain about but after Knight D7 white
is going to play E4 bring the Knight to
F4 play Rook E1 and and Target
E6 so H not so simple not so simple guys
E5 uh we can even take and the queen has
to take back because of Queen D5 check
actually in the
air oh sorry and thank you for telling
me screen is off
center my viewing experience not like
this thanks for telling me guys that's
why that's why I read the chats that's
why I read the
chats
there we go should be
fixed what was cut off the a file not
too much happening on the a file I
promise you
that at least there's nothing uh
happening on the a file Magnus a bit
defensive here a little bit
defensive Knight F6 well let's say
magnus's position is totally fine um but
first time we've actually seen him a
little bit on Def defensive here Rook e
7 Rook e 8 uh might come next Rook e is
a nice move defense C7 and defense
E6 uh I believe that's going to be what
we see G5 hyper
aggressive Knight back to
G2 and then maybe Rook
E7 I think that Magnus still wants to
potentially double up but G5 he's uh
he's going for it Magnus I don't think
has been down on time in any game that
uh that I've seen so far so that seems
pretty uh like a a very good uh
Rhythm to keep so that sometimes people
have different games I know sometimes I
can play a great game where I'm way
ahead of time compared to my opponents
but seems like Magnus is just doing that
consistently it's almost like a a rule
he makes for himself that you know I
think I heard Bobby fiser say that you
know whenever your opponent makes a move
try to think for the same amount of time
as him and if Magnus Carlson is the best
player in the world you know there's not
many positions where other people can
think uh about the best move or what the
best move would be and find it faster
than than mag he simply knows the most
uh variety of positions in the world so
he's the one uh trying to open up the
king side here and white plays for the
queen side with C5 and this end game
looks a little bit better for Magnus
after takes takes there's a nice outpost
on D5 for the Knight King comes to F7
white does get the C file but uh the
Knight covers this Pawn so now black can
shift his attention to protecting D6 so
that is if white switches the Knight
there I think Knight F2 is is a good
move here Knight F2 to and Knight E4
threatening both of those pawns King is
probably going to come to F7 uh and then
E7 oops sorry Knight F2 Knight E4 and
then maybe Rook G8 or G4 to defend that
so I think King E7 is uh it's going to
be the next move here and then perhaps
G4 King E7 and
G4 oh Rook G8 is possible too but then
there's also Rook C8 so I'm not sure um
not sure if that's the best course of
action G4 I like that because if F4 all
of a sudden the the light squares there
are noticeable white is uh is doing
totally fine here we're going to see A3
and maybe bring a king to D3 but uh I
don't think Magnus is unhappy with his
position even trading knights with
something like Knight F6 if that can
happen uh is is definitely favorable for
for black I mean in a rook end game or
something the reason that white would
have the advantage here is if he keeps
the pieces on the board and stays in
this not middle game but uh end game
with a lot of material still left Knight
G5 try to keep both pairs of Rooks on
the board bring the king to to D3 with
of course the move A3 so we don't
blender our Rook Magnus has to deal with
Knight G5 now what is he going to do
about
that I wonder the Knight can always come
to C7 to defend that but it's very
passive it's very passive what is he
going to do
here there's no Knight
F6 uh what oh is he going for activity
here is he going to play Rook
C8 oh excuse me I thought I thought he
was going to play Rook C8 and give up
that pawn I was a bit confused for a sec
but he found a nice way to regroup and
Knight C7 yeah okay wow nice way to
regroup there King D7 Rook E8 and he
doesn't have to really displace en's
pieces or put them on bad squares that
was
uh my opinion guys that was a really
nice maneuver there I didn't didn't see
that one coming at
all now that the ewn is protected
time starts to become a factor and we
might see black continue to push with B5
B4 bring a rook up to B5 and and maybe
swinging over to D5 or F5 the question
is whether there is some draw here with
Knight D5 Knight G5 I think white would
be happy to go for one at this
moment maybe Knight G5 Knight C7 well
Knight C7 is forced here actually unless
he wants to do what I was mentioning
last move which is the possibility of
playing Rook C8 giving up a pawn but
that just doesn't seem does doesn't seem
feasible uh you can no you can't play
this move you're going to lose this pawn
it looks
like oh it's going to say unless he
plays Rook there Knight check and then
um Knight takes H5 actually the Knight
might get trapped there um it looks like
this way King
E7 Knight E4 and he wants to put the
Knight back there and then Magnus wants
to defend with Rook to H6 it looks
like complicated game I I feel like
Magnus has a draw in hand if he wants it
but he looks like he's really trying to
play for the
win the question is whether he's going
to admit that he either does or does not
like his position enough to to not play
on but I like Rook H6 I was going to say
his F5 a move there but there's no good
discovered attack with the
Knight now this Pawn is defended there's
no Knight H7 like last time but there is
this move oh man he played that so fast
as well because if Pawn takes let me
just show you guys what was in the
position there King there let's say Rook
to C1 is crushing with Knight E6 and
King here Rook C1 wins the Knight back
to the live position here after uh
Magnus played Rook to E8 Rook C1 was
played with the tricky idea of takes
takes and Rook takes E8
winning now the time is getting very
even this is the the first game that
we've seen Magnus Carlson in real
trouble so guys pay attention to this
one because this could be one of the
only games that Magnus Carlson has an
actual chance to lose a real chance to
lose uh with
black what do we play here is D5 a
move o what what do we think about D5 is
that an idea it might be a little bit
too crazy but it kind of looks cool yeah
D5 D5
this is what I was saying because if
Pawn takes the same tactic is there
black has to play E5 and now are we
going to see a nice move Knight E4
Knight D6 okay Knight D6 Knight takes D5
what was his idea here Rook D2 but
then oo this is very nice Knight F6 Rook
check King back and maybe Rook takes D6
so oh gives up the exchange but
unfortunately you're also losing the D6
Pawn
oh man guys Magnus Carlson down uh on
material and ahead slightly on the clock
but you have to feel that this is uh
definitely winning for white it comes
down to whether this Knight which is
absolutely the best piece in a Time
scramble is going to be a problem or not
Rook E1 followed by Rook B3 looks like a
very devastating threat so black doesn't
have any time to generate counterplay
yeah rookie one is actually just a
crushing move
here
oo got to play King D4 but then Rook uh
here and the Knight has to move and
there's Rook D1 at the end so yeah white
is going to get the Rooks off here
oh oh my
goodness uh that is actually just a free
night Magnus just hung a piece it
happens to the best of us it happens to
the world champion oh my
goodness look at
that guys well Magnus Carlson just went
went down to Y have 11 from Russia um a
very well played game and it looked like
Magnus could have had a draw and I think
he was trying too hard to have his
position you know maybe a little bit
worse but then try to play for a win and
outplay his opponent but we saw that
happen maybe to nakur early in the
tournament when the position is a draw
objectively sometimes you just have to
take it even though you want to beat
your opponent so maybe that creeped in
here a little bit Magnus tried to play
subpar Moves In order to keep the
position going and not uh and not play
uh not play for a draw but a draw would
have been a good result for the
tournament so wow Magnus Carlson goes
down here he uh he does hang a piece at
the end but let's be fair guys even with
King D4 um King F2 is coming and I'm I'm
sure that uh White can put that position
away for the full point so it's not like
his uh mistake had a huge impact on the
game um because I think it was lost in
the final position but okay no no
excuses that is a very big blender for
the world
champion Anna Rudolph in chat Lawrence
Trent I've seen uh I've seen that duo in
commentary for proess which I which I
really enjoy so it's uh nice to see the
pair of them in chat enjoying what is
definitely the strongest title Tuesday
I've ever seen or ever commentated uh
and as we go into the last round uh this
game is a draw we're going to follow one
more game there we go maybe this will be
the last game of the round but there's
only one round to go let me update you
guys on the standings because this is
going to get very intense we have Magnus
Carlson dropping way out of the lead 6
and a half points out of eight we have
elage Safari seven points you have gen
11 just defeated Magnus Carlson also has
uh seven points and we have who in the
heck is Pedro Martinez
91 2338 from I'm not sure where where
are you from Pedro Spain Aid Master 2300
with 7 out of eight that is a ridiculous
score oh my
goodness what a what a result or what a
score for the the Fay Master
there well Magnus is not going to be
happy with losing I think he'll be
okay with maybe hanging the piece
because uh where he's really going to be
upset is
uh getting into that position in the
first place he he shouldn't be uh trying
to play on when the position is maybe uh
objectively a draw so maybe that's going
to be what he's kicking himself for guys
um in other news I guess uh it's not
magnus's tournament to win anymore uh
Pedro Martinez 91 I don't know who you
are but you have seven points out of
eight uh
I agree guys vote for Pedro vote for
Pedro this is definitely a vote for
Pedro because I don't know who that
player is but what a tournament from him
we might have to spectate his game in
the last round he might be playing on
board one there's three players with
seven points who are the favorites to
finish top three and then we've got
Alexander shimanov benjaman Bach Magnus
Carlson mvl we got JC Bara Alexander
moscalenko um just a a bunch of people
at 6 and A2 points but it looks like the
winning score is probably going to be
eight points guys as I predicted earlier
on this is a very tough tournament eight
points out of nine is a monster score
but you're going to need that in order
to win this event okay we have a few
more games still
going let's maybe stick with this one
until the round is over looks like white
is going to try to trick black
here see if he knows uh see if he knows
what to do or how to probe here but um
no drawn by agreement maybe this one has
been going for a while I'm not
sure all right that game is over and
there's only one more game left in the
round this is the last game of round
eight before we get into the money round
guys which is going to be so exciting
because Magnus Carlson just lost the
game there's no way he finishes in first
place uh that is a disappointing result
for him um but we'll have to we'll have
to see how the final standings look
Magnus needs to win his last round for a
respectable finish from his uh for for
his standards let's say and here we're
basically seeing a drawn position uh
being played out here this is the last
game of the round um but the standings
uh near the top of the table are very
very interesting we would never expect
Pedro Martinez to be ahead of Magnus
Carlson I don't even know who who did
Pedro Martinez play in this tournament
that's uh that's
crazy
who did Pedro play maybe someone can uh
help me out in the chat anybody
following Pedro Martinez uh he must have
scored some big wins in order to uh in
order to get here and it's not going to
be Pedro H sorry it could be Pedro
against Magnus I can't remember if elage
and ygi have played before if not we're
going to see those two at seven points
play each other and Pedro at seven
points is going to drop down and play
Magnus at 6 and A2 that is a very likely
result well there you go that could
happen and then we're basically seeing
a h guys playing on here when they
shouldn't this is a draw that we're just
waiting for but uh might take a while to
to
materialize not going to be uh not going
to be giving too much commentary on this
one we'll just wait for for this to be
over with the likely result of a draw
but we we'll see we'll see
Anything Can
Happen Pedro beat Anderson
Silva Pedro beat Anderson Silva he beat
genas K Conrad Holt that's uh those are
some big results
guys that's uh that's pretty
serious okay what are we doing here oh I
hate when games go this
long
yeah okay check check someone claim a
three-fold there we
go I don't mind long games but when
they've been a draw for about 100 moves
that is uh time to call it quits guys
the money round is it going to be Magnus
Carlson against Pedro that's what I want
to
see no it isn't I think maybe those two
guys at the top have I've already played
Magnus Carlson is playing shimanov but
guys we need to pay attention to uh two
games in particular Alexander moscalenko
here playing Black against efan 11 and
the other game we have to check is elage
Safari seven points playing Pedro so I'm
just going to see how the opening goes
in this game and then I'm going to go to
the next
game making a draw for the guys in the
lead is not a uh not a crazy thing but I
do want to check the other game because
we haven't seen Pedro play at all I
don't know anything about this guy seven
points and look at him go is this even a
variation in the French what is
this Knight E4 isn't that just like a
blender Pedro played n okay guys Pedro
played Knight to E4 which my to my
knowledge is a questionable
line like definitely definitely not a
move and then he offered a draw to elage
Safari Pedro is a
legend Pedro is an absolute
Legend let's stick with this game and uh
and see see what happens
here if he wins guys uh vote for Pedro
for sure we need to start making the
Napoleon Dynamite
t-shirts
thank you for the confirmation Lawrence
this line is a little bit dubious but
definitely workable uh kind of like my
qua uh this this mop top I've got up
here so it's it's kind of messy but you
know the right guy can make it work type
of thing uh we could definitely say that
knight4 much much liked my uh my hair
it's not for everyone but uh if Pedro
can make this work then you would say
that you know that makes him look very
good because the variation might be a
bit dubious if Pedro can make it work
it's extremely impressive on his part so
I'll take the same compliment that you
know if I can make this dubious
hairstyle work that uh must say
something about me so I'll take it I'll
take it Lawrence that's that's a fair
assessment that's a fair assessment and
Pedro Martinez speaking of making it
work now elage Safari offered a draw to
Pedro decline it decline it Pedro say no
say no he said
no he declined
it he declined it guys Pedro is a legend
he completely equalized that of the
opening and now elage Safar offering a
draw
and Pedro says
no Pedro says no I love
it well basically the position I would
say is more or less equal I would
slightly prefer white perhaps because
the Knight on G6 looks very bad to me
and uh the queen side majority is always
nice to have in an end
game yeah guys the strategies from Pedro
offers a draw early guy says no Then the
GM offers a draw later and Pedro says
no what what a
beast I don't like the Knight on G6 here
um I'll say that
but I'm also wondering uh it's hard to
really place an evaluation here I mean
it's it's obviously just just about
equal um but black wants to play on you
got to respect that maybe C3 and King C2
Rook e one of course uh on the
cards but Pedro uh showing no mercy here
another draw offered by
white another draw offered by white are
we going to see the
decline 3 2 1 decline it oh he didn't do
it on my Q come on Pedro you going to
take that draw
no Pedro wants to play on let's go let's
go
Pedro oh this is giv me some energy guys
seeing uh Pedro uh decline all of
safar's draw offers he's starting to
reroute his Knight he's going to play
Maybe H6 Knight E4 G5 uh-huh he's going
to trade one pair of Rooks and not not a
second maybe F6 stop Knight E5 yep so
I'm talking about Pedro H6 G5 this Pawn
majority on the king side with the
king's assistant is more workable than
the queen side cuz if Black's pawns were
all the way up here then white could
maybe start to probe against the
weaknesses but wh's pawns are already
very Advanced so black can start to play
H6 G5 uh King F7 here Rook
C7 Pedro is uh playing for the win
against elage Safari he's like what is
this 500 more than 500 points in
Underdog that is
ridiculous I I've never even seen Vegas
odds like
that Pedro
Martinez what a beast a beast from
Spain this is pure
entertainment this is pure entertainment
I
agree it ain't over till Pedro says it's
over Pedro says no I like that I'm going
to start chanting that every time I see
a draw
offer
[Music]
P El Pedro say
no Pedro says
no okay we got some shuffling going on
uh maybe he's just catching up on time
though we'll see I don't expect Pedro to
go for a draw rookie two oh come on
elage you know you want to draw it's all
up to Pedro Pedro says yes or
no King E7
I like H6 and and G5 though I want to do
that
plan King
F7 oh this this is a
repetition okay there we go the draw is
on the table that's crazy though let's
take a look at the other game guys let's
quickly go to yev L and Alexander
moscalenko because
if Levan as wh wins this game then he
wins the tournament outright there's
nothing that anyone else can do about it
uh because of that draw seven and a half
for Safari and for
Pedro and everyone else is still playing
here with six and a half points but
nobody can catch eight points so if
white wins there's your tournament
Victor there is your tournament
Victor Pedro is from Spain like David
Anton yeah who who gave hikaro a run for
his money and played an amazing
tournament in jalter but uh it looks
like Spain won't be taking uh that many
championships away not uh not this time
we have uh NAA taking jalter ahead of
David Anton and it looks like someone
else is going to take uh first place in
this
tournament just to confirm Pedro has the
worst tie breaks than Safari so he will
technically finish uh tied for
some other place uh oh no there's no
Rook C8
okay so the the prizes guys just remind
you are shared but technically they they
use a tiebreak system to um place these
players uh ranked one two or three uh I
think black is much better here um if
white can get an outside pass Pawn then
I oh disagree but hang on did he just
hang a pawn
there moscalenko declined to draw by the
way and then hung a pawn I was going to
say with the pawn on a light Square then
all of a sudden I I like black because
the uh the E Pawn is running and there's
some chances around the king but maybe
uh he just blundered everything oops
excuse me not that Arrow Knight G4 and
maybe E3 is coming and he's stopping
that E3 is still coming jeez this is
maybe not so easy to play with
White Queen D3 of course attacking and
threatening
E3 it's Queen F3 a move
I like Queen F3 you can also play this
but then there's Queen C4 so Queen F3
and if Queen C4 is there E3 yeah E3
looks good Bishop takes Queen takes with
check and you keep your knight there
well E3 and then Bishop E1 and then some
king
move maybe
here even E2 actually E2 Bishop F2 then
we just got to do some calculation there
what uh what should be played then you
can start running your king that pawn is
very close to queening moscalenko once
again declined to draw Queen D1 he
played ooh and he's not playing he's not
playing here and going for the
draw but white uh once again if white
wins then he wins the tournament if not
we may have a a two to three-way tie for
first place at seven and a half points
guys there's a lot lot of energy in the
chat today guys this is uh a big
viewership what's up to everybody who's
watching we got Magnus Carlson in the
tournament we uh we had the most title
players like three or four maybe five
people from the top 10 of the world were
playing strongest title Tuesday I ever
seen and Magnus Carlson lost the game so
the hype has just been unreal the hype
has been
unreal Magnus uh has won his games but
he's at seven and a half but guys Magnus
has worse tie breaks than Pedro Ro and
JC Ibara has just won and he has 7 and a
half now ahead of Pedro so this is all
coming down to tie breaks guys about who
is going to technically finish first
second third although a reminder that
the money is shared so again if white
can win this game he wins the tournament
but it's just feeling less and less
likely he's got three seconds he's he's
almost going to lose well hang on oh no
there's mate oh he blundered mate oh man
he blundered
mate oh that's too bad y have gen
11 poor guy he does not even finish
close to the money as Alexander
moscalenko moves to S and a half points
as well it looks like the standings are
going to
finish um unless someone else has some
very very good standings uh there's only
one more game I believe that can impact
the standings and let's take a look at
it's the game of mvl both players at 6
and 1/2 points 7 and A2 is the leading
score right now mvl with black playing
for the win this looks like it could be
a draw but I would say black has all the
chances to win this
game okay maybe Queen B2 and can we
really avoid all the checks here
A2 yeah and basically it's just going to
be uh a hunt hunt for that
King can he escape checks well certainly
not this way no now he's just Dr on oh
no King there check and now King
up is there anything here rly
block check King back and then just
Queen what's that move just
Queen oo at least we had to keep
checking okay this is just over yeah no
Queen H4 mate that was the last trick
ooh that puts uh mvl into contention
guys let me check the standings
oo unfortunately his tie breaks were not
not very good elage Safari guys best tie
breaks in the tournament he finishes
first place 7 and half out of nine and
second is going to be Alexander
moscalenko with that Victory as opponent
y have G 11 hung Checkmate in one move
and JC iaro looks like he's going to
take third but remember that there's
going to be even Magnus Carlson as well
sharing the money and Pedro Martinez an
mvl the money does get shared but for
the purpose of the standings you're
going to see on your screen it looks
like Safari moscalenko and
Ibara and we'll wait for the final
couple games to finish in this
event but this has been uh an absolute
roller coaster Magnus uh lost a game
which no one could ever expect oh King
takes E5 what a horrible blender oh man
yeah Magnus lost a game and uh he did
not finish on the podium which he's
definitely not going to be happy about
other highlights I mean we had an FM
2300 finish tied for first place which
is completely ridiculous great
tournament by him 7 and a half out of
nine um and I'm not even sure if he lost
a game I think he may have just yeah I
think he just drew his uh his we to
seven and a half he won and Drew so
that's uh that's a big result right
there
and um other than that we had some of
the the most strongest tournament uh
some of the most title players I've ever
seen in a title Tuesday so um on top of
that the numbers have just been insane
well over 1500 viewers watching so
thanks for everybody who who stuck
around uh for this long and hopefully
enjoyed uh enjoyed the
commentary um this has been a a super
exciting tournament uh again I wish I
could maybe play but it's also uh it's
also very nice to commentate because
when I'm playing I would miss the games
that Carlson and the other guys are
playing and when I'm commentating I get
to look at everything so that's that's
really nice that's really nice as well
hope everyone uh enjoyed here looks like
we're waiting for this one game maybe
there's another one to finish before the
standings pop up on your screen this
looks like it's going to be over in a
second but the standings are already
confirmed this uh the one two3 is
already done there we go white gets a
new Queen this one's
over this one is over standings already
determined we're just waiting for the
all the games to
finish for
uh for us to move on to the standings
this is the other game that's still
going o Rook against Knight this one
could go for a while but uh yeah
basically the standings are already done
so quite a lot of players tied for first
which was 7 and a half out of nine this
was a very entertaining tournament we
had NAA in there at the beginning Carana
as well as well and uh you know there
was only uh only one Survivor we had uh
you know Wesley so playing uh for the
first time in a title Tuesday as far as
I know Magnus Carlson playing for the
first time um just the strongest event
that you could ask for and on top of
that you know we had an FM finish ahead
of Magnus you know finish ahead of
Wesley so just uh crazy stuff happened
this event so this was by far the most
fun I've had commentating a title to for
sure um Anna thanks so
much Lawrence
Trent uh thanks for being here as well
in the chat and everybody who's on
chess.com TV as well as uh
twitch.tv/ chess remember guys there is
no uh late event there's no early and
late there's only one title Tuesday so
this was it this this was uh this was
the big event um so don't be showing up
later later tonight and and uh wondering
where where I am where the title
Tuesday's at because there's only one
event for today h and this was it there
you see on your screen elaj Safari
Alexander moscalenko JC Bara gold Sila
barns but like I said Magnus Carlson mvl
and Pedro did as well share uh the money
in this tournament so six players tied
for first very exciting I uh hope you
guys enjoyed that will be all for me
International masteron Hamilton I had a
blast there was uh more people than I've
ever seen watching uh a title Tuesday
before and definitely the strongest one
I've ever commentated so uh I had fun
and I will see you guys for the next
title Tuesday next month take care
everybody and we'll see you next
time